hello welcome everybody to the Yale
quantum Institute opening grand opening
I'm Douglas stone theoretical physicists
working in the department of applied
physics and I'm the deputy director of
the new Institute here and this is an
exciting day for us and for you and
millions across the web
today we're officially opening the
Institute and we're gonna have a panel
discussion first and then the president
of Yale Peter salv a will be here and we
will have a ribbon-cutting which I think
will be memorable so don't race out and
and then we'll have some festivities
afterwards this place will be a home for
interdisciplinary cooperation at both
among Yale researchers and visiting
scientists in the area of quantum
science and today we're delighted to
present the panel on the coming of a new
information age with two leaders in the
field of quantum information science
before we get into that discussion let
me present a bit of background brief
overview of why we're here today now for
those not well versed in quantum physics
and I do see a few don't worry there
won't be an exam at the end anyway so
roughly 90 years ago physicists achieved
a mathematical theory of physics at the
atomic scale which we call quantum
mechanics and this was the culmination
of a 25-year effort initiated by Max
Planck and Albert Einstein and others
and the theory developed then has been
expanded and tested in thousands of ways
since and it's so far past all tests
with flying colors the theory has been
essential in unleashing the technologies
of the 20th century the Atomic Age and
the Information Age or as I might say
now the first information age however
from the very beginning this theory
created disquiet among physicists
philosophers and others because its
structure seemed to abandon strict
causality and also seemed to undermine
the objectivity of the laws of physics
measurement and the observer seemed to
play a fundamental role in the theory is
tine perhaps the greatest critic of the
theory used to summarize these concerns
with two pithy phrases God does not play
dice and do you really think the moon
isn't there when you're not looking at
it one can identify three concepts in
quantum physics which are troubling in
that way the first one is that
microscale physical systems can exist
simultaneously in two different states
and only when they're directly measured
do they make up their mind and randomly
fall into one or the other this
principle is called superposition of
states and you'll hear a lot about it
shortly because it's important for
quantum information science this is also
the idea behind the famous Schrodinger
cat thought experiment in which a cat is
hooked up to a gizmo which may or may
not poison it and leaves it then in an
uncertain state of being alive and dead
at the same time closely related to
superposition is Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle which says that
you cannot measure all the properties of
a physical system on the micro scale at
once if you know one thing about it
another complementary property will then
be in a spread out superposition of
states and is hence very uncertain the
third strange thing is the one that
Einstein was the first to notice this
property is called entanglement in which
two separate quantum systems become
correlated at a distance even if they're
individually uncertain like two magic
coins which are flipped in different
rooms and when one of them comes up
heads the other always comes up tails or
vice versa
Einstein called this spooky action at a
distance and he hated it taken together
these three properties were understood
to imply fundamental impediments to
human knowledge because of this quantum
weirdness there were things we could
know in classical physics that we can't
know because the quantum laws hold and
until now the great inventions based on
quantum physics like the transistor and
the laser more or less avoided these
issues
imagine our surprise then when it was
discovered roughly 20 years ago that
there were revolutionary information
processing methods which relied on
precisely the parts of quantum physics
which Einstein hated in which we were
told growing up
we're only of concern to philosophers I
believe this is one of the most
important and surprising developments in
all of science in the past half-century
it created a paradigm shift in how we
think about quantum mechanics and it
launched an interdisciplinary field of
quantum information science which is now
a worldwide effort involving academia
government and industry while this field
encompasses several areas such as
communications networking sensing a
central area focus is quantum
computation and specifically on building
a computer which can solve problems
totally beyond the reach of our best
conventional computers initially the
field of quantum computation was simply
a series of theoretical and conceptual
discoveries we had no good idea how to
make the hardware in the lab that would
realize any of these ideas so the
beginning of this field was the
exploration of many very different
approaches to making quantum computing
devices one of the scientists who
appreciated this paradigm shift first is
here today this is Raymond Laflamme
professor Laflamme is a professor of
physics at the University of Waterloo in
Canada where he holds a Canada Research
Chair and he's the director of its
Institute for quantum computing he has a
distinguished research career starting
with his PhD work in cosmology under the
supervision I actually said
superposition and my practice under the
supervision of Stephen Hawking at
Cambridge University and then moved on
to the Los Alamos National Laboratory
where he was an early adopter if I could
say that of quantum computation he
pioneered the use of nuclear magnetic
resonance techniques to perform quantum
computation and holds the record for the
largest number of quantum bits employed
in a quantum
processor he's laid down foundational
ideas in quantum error correction and an
optical quantum computing our other
panelists today is our own Rob shulk off
sterling professor and the new director
of our Institute he's a key person on
the Yale team which also includes very
importantly Michel de ray and Steve
Gervin as well as others and that at the
end they have developed superconducting
nano circuits for quantum computing this
is widely recognized as one of the most
innovative and realistic approaches to
achieving a large-scale quantum computer
something which I must admit has not yet
been achieved we will not hear about
that yet today the dozens of research
groups in academia and industry that
have adopted the hardware and techniques
developed at Yale including the now
famous transmen qubit design demonstrate
the promise of this approach moderating
our discussion today we're very
fortunate to have Joe palca Joe is a
science correspondent for National
Public Radio he came to journalism after
receiving his PhD in Experimental
Psychology he's of course known for his
ability to communicate science to the
public and is currently running a series
on NPR called Joe's big idea which I
really love and which seeks to capture
the creativity inherent in scientific
research quoting from Joe's bio he has
won numerous awards several of which
came with attractive certificates the
same could be said of our panelists as
well so without further ado we will get
on to the discussion
okay so are you gonna start things off
by telling us why we're here today Rob
sure so yeah thank you all for joining
us for the grand opening as Doug said
the Institute was formed about a year
ago but just recently we've moved into
this new space and we're very happy to
be taking taking it over today and the
goal of the institute is basically to
build the Yale community in this in this
area to bring people together from
across campus and the different
disciplines and to host visitors from
around the world who are experts in this
and have them come and interchange their
ideas with us and eventually to grow
this area further okay so let me just
tell you I mean yes that's the Great
Communicator I'm gonna communicate to
you what we're gonna do this this
afternoon for the next half an hour or
40 minutes or so and that is I'm gonna
have a discussion with these guys and
it's ray and Rob and Joe not or Joey and
and and but you're welcome to join in so
we have an extra microphone over there
and wave your hand at me at some point
if you hear if you have a question
that's really pressing and I'll walk
over to you with the microphone and you
can ask it and then we'll have the
celebration and the ribbon-cutting which
is going to be spectacular though I have
no idea what it is yeah but but but
seriously so to start with looking from
Canada why why is it an appropriate time
for this institute to come into
existence so to answer this I'll go a
little bit of a detour and I bring you a
little closer to the night and after the
detour you'll see exactly what where it
comes why is it exactly the right time
and I'll start by what is the motivation
and then I'll be kind of I won't make
the difference between the motivation of
me as a personal and individual and the
one as my hat as being the director of
the Institute for quantum computing it
all starts with some form of curiosity
and
which leads me to the next question
which would be why are weaker yes and I
think we're curious before because of
Darwin's principle and maybe being in
the u.s. compared to Canada I have to
watch out going down that line and it's
Darwin's principle because humans have
realized that by harnessing curiosity we
can survive better and make our life
much much bigger much easier to live and
here's how I go from curiosity to make
your life better
people like me Rob many people in this
room are physicists who focus the
curiosity on trying to understand
properties of the royal around us and
this is amazing by itself that we can
understand some properties of nature and
when we understand some property the
next step is that we learn how to
predict these properties in different
situation and when we can predict the
situation the next step is really to try
to control them and when we can control
them we can do the next step developing
technologies and technologies have an
kobol impact in society and I should say
in this cycle that started with
curiosity going to understanding
prediction control the arrow goes down
at every step not everything we
understand we can predict not everything
we predict we can control but when we
arrive at the end there are some
technologies that are really changing
the fabric of society and really
changing humans don't really think the
way they do things and I'll give a few
examples if you go back twenty thousand
years fire like in it's a fire was this
thing that nobody kind of really
understood people who scared out some
crazy humans when there a fire able to
kind of bring fire through a bunch of
rocks and kind of melt metals and led to
agriculture agriculture made people
gather together because they could make
food that lasts longer okay I haven't
gotta go the next cycle of this with
skillet theme some years after
electromagnetism and these were things
from the past that the really changed
society like the way we communicate with
each other is
I think I look at my kids the way that
communicates is very different the way
that I do it or the way that my parents
do it
so something is very different but that
was the past why today because we look
to the future and we look at what are
the force of nature that we've started
to understand in the 20th century in
quantum mechanics is kind of one example
of this and we are the stage industry
where we have started to control quantum
system control in a way where they are
getting bigger and bigger and pet can do
this so this is why I believe that we
are just in the part of history where we
can learn how to develop technologies
which are fully working on the quantum
mechanical principle ok so so one of the
things that that I'm always trying to do
is to make these abstract concepts more
concrete for somebody on a day to day
basis so what is the reason that
somebody listening to this brought you
know listening to us on the web or
listening to me talk about quantum
computing on the radio what what are
they going to take that's going to
affect their lives either today or in
ten years from now well I think as very
was saying it takes a long time
sometimes to go from understanding to
control into real applications so I
think for many of us working in this
field we have a sense that there's a
great untapped power here but we're not
at all sure that we know all the things
that it will be good for so often we are
focusing on building a quantum computer
an information processing device that
uses these rules of quantum mechanics
because that's kind of the ultimate or
the hardest challenge to master but in
addition to just making computing faster
letting us store more information and
things there are other applications of
these ideas of quantum information that
could be really impactful in people's
lives better ways of sensing my needs
signals better ways of transmitting
information better ways of securing
people's privacy there's a whole host of
things so so what kind of what kind of a
physicists do you need to explore these
questions because if this is a field
that doesn't
it doesn't take all of one part of
physics and another and it combines a
lot right
so it's certainly things that people are
open-minded but you profess your
question by saying what kind of
physicist and I think we need more than
that says we need computer scientists
like what have a great thing at the
Institute where we are we formed this
Institute which kind of brings different
silos of universities where like you
have physics department chemistry
departments math departments and
although ideally people things that they
all talk to each other in practice like
there's these boundaries and they make
boundaries by making different buildings
so our Institute bring people from pure
math from and world where this funny
thing that they have a faculty of
mathematics of a bunch of different
Department of Mathematics so we have
computer science coming at directs
optimization which is cryptography apply
maths chemistry physics electrical
Computer Engineering and when you say
what kind of physicists we mean maybe
you want to convert all these different
into physicists so that they can talk in
a very different way mhm yeah I mean
that's one of the exciting things I
think is right now we're in the process
of creating a brand new field maybe it's
just quantum science or quantum
engineering eventually but it's going to
take not just physicists or
mathematicians or computer scientists
but also electrical engineers material
scientists a whole host of things and so
exactly one of the features or functions
of of an institute like this is to try
and yeah bring people together from
these different disciplines and you know
fill in fill in the gaps and and you
know learn to translate between the
different fields so you said that
there's been an explosion in the last
five to ten years or maybe Doug you said
that um what precipitated that and who's
paying for it because ultimately well
seriously I mean you you know there was
an explosion in cold fusion years ago
but it was more of a fizzle
it would have been good there would have
been an exposed there was there was a
there was a momentary fantastic amount
of interest in know but but people
they're willing to bet their careers
that there's gonna be something here so
what what made that happen well I would
say they've gone first piece is that
we've all live in the information age we
have this widget which are around us
that we use and we see that it has
changed our life although short they
have been and changed the life of our
kids so there has been a sinker ball
technological revolution using
information and with quantum computing
we are learning that what this
information is is not the complete
picture that there are sets of problems
that people who are saying okay can we
solve this and then they are they seem
to be intractable and these quantum
devices quantum computers can do it so
there is a fundamental discovery that
we've learned that information is very
different than what people have been
doing and so this is really if you are a
scientist you want to make your mark and
mark in your life here's an
unfortunately I mean to give the
specific history as Doug was sort of
saying in his introduction the
understanding of quantum mechanics
itself is relatively new only a century
old maybe but it was sort of in the mid
90s that the ideas of shore and the
factorization algorithm and the ideas of
quantum error correction kind of hit and
turned it from a real niche into
something that then began to attract
more and more attention and of course
there are initial applications that are
of relevance for for governments and for
cryptography and things like that so
they were one of the initial funders and
so on but now in you know we're sort of
at this interesting stage where we're
seeing more and more players getting
into the field private sector is
beginning to pick this up because they
see that it may be really a profound
thing that comes in only a decade or so
that to know that I'm sure because these
companies they don't jump in unless they
think there's going to be a payoff but
this is one of the things that I've
always found amusing so ray you said
there's there are problems that quantum
computers can solve that other computers
can't solve but right now there isn't a
quantum computer so you've you've got a
theoretical device that's gonna solve a
problem but you haven't built it yet
yeah but there are certain problems
where it matters that you solve that I'm
not only today but what happens if you
solve them in the future in cryptography
is an example of this the codes that
people are using and the internet today
using the cellphone rely on factoring
numbers and things we can which we
cannot do efficiently with classical
computers but quantum computers could do
it so if you exchange information on the
internet today and somebody store it and
you it is encrypted then we finally
build a quantum computer in 15 years
down the line we can go back and create
kind of find out what has been exchanged
now for most things I people exchange on
the Internet
we don't really care because in fact
boring though do not want to know know
the email of the person who wants to
become president of the United States
for example for example our credit card
numbers will change but there are the
things that we start to care about your
health records they are started to be
exchanged through the internet which
means when we have a quantum computer we
will be able to go back and find out
what the health problems I'm Canadians I
have a social you and us are and much
more trouble than we are out there so
immigration will be limited but we are
policy person level so there are
problems even if you don't have it pose
a threat in fact there was a very
interesting piece of news in August that
the National Security Agency in the u.s.
made official that in their future codes
they wanted them to be quantum safe and
they were asking the community to come
with suggestion of which classical codes
can be quite I'm safe resistant even to
the building of a quantum
yeah yeah and that's a yeah absolutely
which means that the NSA has realized
that there will be a quantum computer
the chance is very high in the earth to
protect the nation against these devices
so they are they are on their way but
besides the security things we know that
there are scientific applications at
least right so trying to simulate what
collection of atoms in some novel
material will do is a very challenging
problem for the same reason that a
quantum computer is very powerful
because it becomes exponentially hard to
to actually simulate it using the
techniques we know today and so you know
again there's sort of it's become
apparent in this last decade or two that
there's a power here in storing the
information and manipulating it this way
that you know we have hints of what it
can do we know that some of these things
would be very useful so simulating new
materials is I'm told a reasonable
fraction something like 30% of all
supercomputer usage for scientific
applications in the country now so that
would be already a big a big thing at
least for scientists but again if you
look at the history of regular computing
we didn't know that we would have all
these things like the internet and cell
phones and all of that until we started
to have you know fast classical
computers that were cheap and
mass-producible like classical so so
explain what classic yes right but
explain explain this remind people why
there's a limit why the classical
computers are gonna sort of run out of
gas at some point right so the the other
reason that people especially in the
private sector are interested in quantum
computing is that the you know all of
the current information age has been
driven by Moore's law or the fact that
your miniaturizing always the size of
the transistors and therefore you're
making it cheaper and easier to produce
them you can make a faster computer one
that stores more information and so on
and it doubles every 18 months or
something like that but you know
nowadays many of the key dimensions in
the actual transistors you're buying in
your commercial devices are only a few
atoms across so there is a limit coming
soon it's not to many more doublings or
exponential cycles of growth of Moore's
law when we just won't be able to do
things anymore
and so in the in this way and so for you
know today is electrical engineers
worrying about that problem quantum
mechanics is a bug but the hope is that
we can turn it into a feature so if you
accept the fact that when your
transistors are all in atom across or so
or just that your devices behave in the
same way that single atoms do according
to quantum mechanics that then you can
just change your paradigm and and make
something which still functions very
well and maybe even with new
capabilities or functions even better
than what we could have made before and
as you mentioned Moore's Law we do see
the trend as change if you look in the
last five years
SOI the slope as flatline and so we are
there so there's a there's a huge
industry there that's interested in
making sure that they can continue or
that if that paradigm of Moore's law is
going to go away they have to stay on
top of whatever's coming next so they're
exploring lots of things neuromorphic
computing you know neural networks again
things like that and quantum is one of
the things that seems like a tractable
way that you might actually run an end
run around the end of Moore's law but
I'm wondering now so so i i've done some
reporting from the middle east and and
they they are they became wealthy on
energy that was in the ground and that
but they say a lot of the countries
there are saying now no we're not fossil
fuel providers we're energy providers
and we're gonna we're gonna be the world
leaders in solar and we're gonna be the
world leaders in geothermal or whatever
other technique but but i wonder so just
because you are have a lot of oil on the
ground doesn't make you an expert in
other forms of energy and I'm wondering
if the computing companies I mean they
build today's computers but maybe it's a
completely different entity that's going
to be able to capture a market of
quantum computing that has nothing to do
with a company that's built on silicon
chips I mean is there a reason to think
that the Intel's of the world are the
ones that are going to carry us forward
into the quantum communicate computing
age I would say absolutely not okay and
if you look at the history of change in
technology typically the big
Bennie's cannot that didn't you change I
thought I saw a report at some point in
the 1950s there was a report from the US
government saying that the industry of
the vacuum tube is in really good shape
we should keep investing and because
this is the future and of the 50 to 75
big companies making vacuum tubes and
nearly 50 I think five survive and then
the post 1960s
so there is an inc of all opportunities
more young people to run on this
opportunity right we don't know you know
exactly what a quantum computer may look
like I mean one of the things we
specialize in here at Yale is sort of
solid-state electronic devices that can
perform these these quantum functions
and in that particular case there
probably are a lot of things we can
learn from the traditional computer
industry they can help accelerate some
of the development and so on but it's
going to require them to also develop
new skills and you know bring in as we
said other other people and so you know
our role as academics right is to is to
try and look ahead and and be bold and
take lots of risks and develop those
innovations so I have a neighbor in
Washington DC who's just started as a
freshman here at Yale and I'm gonna go
back and tell him well I'm not gonna see
him for a couple weeks but I'll see him
at the vacation and if he'll finished
he'll finished his first semester here
and I'm gonna tell him you should think
about quantum computing and here are the
classes you should take what should he
be taking at this point in order to
prepare himself haha is that funny you
should take my introductory
undergraduate class on quantum mechanics
it's a it's a really great class I mean
I know it's sort of a junior level
course and you have to be a physics
major really to to sit that course but I
mean I think this is maybe a sign of
where we are in the development so we
don't have a major in quantum computing
yeah and there are maybe a few things
that could be offered in computer
science classes at some you know in the
department's of computer science at some
universities but I think at the moment
you know physics is the discipline which
is most important or most relevant
because that's sort of the the the basis
of of understanding how these devices
work but I think that will evolve and
that will change so I would say the
first course which was on quantum
mechanics in fact are changing the way I
learn quantum mechanics was really
related to what is called spectroscopy
you look at an atom and how it radiates
and kind of the its properties and
quantum information science is really
something about our quantum system
change as a function of time it's we the
dynamics and so you can see you can
which course and I don't know what which
one Yael teaches so I gotta get in
trouble there and you can see already in
physics it is changing the curriculum
you can see this at many places but if
he really wants to do quantum
information science he has to decide
that kind of which part that he likes
and it could be computer science could
be engineering it could be in chemistry
so there's an incredible opportunity
there of all these different places and
I see the real the really neat
development that has happened certainly
the last 20 years often come from people
who are bringing to fields from
different place look at Rob all right he
came from radio astronomy and then he
would say what does this have to do with
quantum computing and it has to do
because he knows superconductivity and
these superconducting detectors very
well so certainly that know that gets
translated and the people make their
marker the one who are able to kind of
grasp things from another area put them
together
like we mentioned this Shor's algorithm
for factoring that somebody was a
computer scientist who knew quad than an
undergrad in physics was able to put the
two pieces together and now they're
interestingly there'll be a generation
probably in Mexico a thousand years of
people who have been trained doing
quantum information science and what
will they do will be really interesting
hmm
Rob you see I'm gonna I'm gonna I
promised I would let other people ask
questions and I will keep that promise
but I'm gonna ask one more you said
earlier that building the quantum
computer is going to be the hardest
problem that because there are others
that are more tractable at the moment
why is it the hardest well I think
that's one reason why quantum computing
is sometimes the poster child of quantum
information science more more generally
basically to have a working and useful
quantum computer you have to master all
the aspects of the quantum domain you
have to be able to create well isolated
systems you have to be able to program
their evolution you have to be able to
control how they're going to change in
time you have to be able to put lots of
them together you have to be able to
measure them be able to do feedback all
sorts of things so it's kind of the
hardest technical challenge if we can do
that we think we will have in essence
you know complete control over all
things you would want to do at the at
the quantum domain you can make a
quantum simulator that studies novel
materials all kinds of things if you can
do parts of that along the way maybe we
can have a small number of bits and
we're good at transmitting them we can
do quantum communication we can ensure
privacy by making things that are
unbreakable to conventional or even
class quantum computers and there's also
some really interesting ideas about
employing the concepts of quantum
information to making yeah sensors that
can measure the temperature in this part
of the cell near the mitochondria
instead of over in this part and that's
not exactly a quantum computer but it's
things where people who are trained in
this area can
make new innovations and we're you know
kind of the ideas of the inspiration of
quantum algorithms can can really lead
to new things that I think we wouldn't
have discovered if we weren't having
people you know sitting down and
pondering how would I build a quantum
computer is it going to require I'm just
thinking now you know I go to these
science fairs with high school students
am I going to start seeing posters from
high school students with quantum
physics and quantum information or was
it still too far I think you will I mean
I think when was the scanning tunneling
microscope invented and then given a
Nobel Prize but there was a few years
ago then in in the the Talent Search one
of the kids built a scanning tunneling
microscope that can you image him
individual atoms in his in his garage
with you know bicycle tubes to make
vibration isolation and things like that
I made a show yeah that'd be great and
and and if any of you are out there I
want you to come work in my lab right
away I do get phone calls high school
students grade 12 who says I had this
project on quantum computing can I enter
you all right does anybody have a
question cuz I can keep going I'm good
at this I've learned how to anybody sure
I mean let me get the microphone so that
we can hear you and you you may want to
introduce yourself as well hi I'm Steve
Garvin I want to ask that question to
start a fight great again Michelle when
I said that so on the New York Times a
couple days ago on the front page there
was a claim made that in delft an
experiment was done to prove that a
measurement on two entangled things
remotely separated instantaneously
changed the other I claim that's sort of
nonsense it's in the New York Times
it wasn't on NPR
and then there's no there's no
experiment you can do that shows you
that the state of the other thing
changed instantaneously anybody want to
comment on that
you guys gonna jump into that one you
want to take it first so I'm not sure
see what you are offended by this
comment you do an experiment you make a
measurement and you see some things in
fact they were not the comment of that
they change instantaneously to have this
change means they've measured something
that changed as a function of time they
don't they moved to it they measure two
different things and they observe
correlations we don't agree with our
usual intuition that we know from the
classical world so this is really what
is behind that experiments and
experiments selfie I don't think you
worry about I think you worry about the
comments Doug made the comment about
Einsteins and spooky action and distance
this is what we're paying because of
Einstein's words and people like this
and use I don't particularly like this
spooky terms or saying that it's magic
or this everything looks magic when we
don't understand that right now and when
we start to use these devices then we
start to understand very well LD be a
hundred years ago if I would have said
to people you'll be in this piece of
metal which weighs 30 tons at 30,000
feet and you'll go between London to
Yale and five hours people would say
you're crazy
makes no sense today we just say yes I
can finally get in there now as a
physicist every time I take off I always
worried I'm the only one in the plane
looking as I hope that all the physics
don't change but it's an amazing thing
that you take off in this thing I mean I
think Steve was trying to start a fight
so I'll jump in so I mean I think also
it illustrates a point we were trying to
make
in this discussion earlier which is some
of the things which are strange and
counterintuitive and so on about quantum
mechanics are because we think about
things or we grew up thinking about
things in kind of outmoded or outdated
ways so the reason this experiment is
funny is there's a photon here and a
photon there and if I really think about
them separately how does this one going
click determine which way that one's
going to go but the way I understand it
right is that's sort of outmoded there
aren't two photons we made a pair of
photons
it's a funny system all one thing which
is delocalized one is over here on this
side of the campus and one is a
kilometer over there but of course you
know because that object is extended and
does you know covers this wide range you
know
poking on it makes it change in both
places at the same time so if you really
accept the idea that an entangled pair
is one odd is one system then I don't
think it's actually so so surprising and
I feel like the more we work in this
area the more we learn to say well ok
that I used to be confused or I used to
be perplexed about these things but now
I've either grown calloused or I've come
to understand it in a better way do you
wanna do you wanna weigh in Michelle
Michelle so putting his hand up let's go
this is amongst the experts now maybe so
of course Steve is provoking us but what
I would what I will answer is that it's
true that you John Alice can write these
articles because in fact we are used to
think about physics as sort of a
billiard ball science we are we we
associate physics with the motion of
things and yes if you look at quantum
mechanics and you apply it to the motion
of a billiard ball it looks it looks
strange but if you take physics and
think about it in terms of information
and that was what rob was saying then
actually quantum physics is actually
much easier to understand and the
classical information
it looks very bizarre if you want to use
it to understand physics so that's also
another way to that's I agree of course
because I learned it from you guys but
but it does make me think that maybe the
one part of the explanation is that if
you said to somebody I'm I I flipped a
coin I I put my thumb up like this in in
New York and then five hours later I was
able to show that it was in a similar
position in London you'd say well that's
impossible you couldn't get there in
five hours but now you can and so maybe
there's a maybe there's some parallel
there I don't know so starting with the
starting with Einstein those so so first
you know I wasn't gonna actually say
that but thank you Einstein in the
quantum Princeton University Press
neighbor back available okay so so so I
initially thought that was really gonna
violate relativity that you could send
information or energy faster than light
and that there was gonna be real
contradiction and then finally you know
like six years after he was quote he
probably figured out earlier he said
well I understand there's no
contradiction but there's something very
unreasonable so so he kind of got rid of
the contradiction so now it's a question
of in his MA I mean there is no
contradiction so this things happening
instantaneously distantly isn't really
happening even by Einstein's definition
okay now the questions they're still
weird things from certain definitions
and what's happened in quantum
information is we realized that those
weird things are the wonderful powerful
productive things that let us do
powerful information processing so my
motto for the new Institute is Yale comm
Institute embrace the weirdness well
actually I was gonna wait hold this
question until the president arrives but
I want to ask it now and because I think
we're he's actually here oh he's here in
the back
oh good hi do you want to come up front
okay
well the question is and it's really
it's their back psychologist unite no
the question I was gonna ask is what
what is it special about Yale that
allowed this Center to start here I mean
you know either it couldn't have gone
other places maybe so but let's let's
say something nice about you why is it
here so I mean I think this is this has
been a really fun ride it's been an
interesting success story I don't think
we really set out to be a powerhouse in
this field exactly and it's not also
sort of the kind of discipline that
we're typically known for so much so but
you know we just sort of we started in I
was lucky enough that I was beginning
here just around the time when quantum
information was was taking off and we
were able to attract some really key
people and and you know build it build a
team here so I think also one of the
things that's been really great about
this is we have a very close working
relationship among the people here on
campus so we're able to sort of
synergize and and do more than we could
have individually you know I think we're
trying to build on that success and and
you know now especially as I think we've
developed some hardware that starts to
be really interesting from the quantum
information or quantum computer science
side we're looking to kind of grow our
presence in in that area which is sort
of maybe the you know right is stronger
in and like you see the strong green
because you know as we develop the
hardware we have to figure out what the
heck we're gonna use it for you know an
interesting parallel is we think of kind
of the software part of computers as
having always been there but of course
when they built the first vacuum tube
computers they didn't really know what
they were gonna do with them so much
there was a guy named John von Neumann
who was a polymath and a genius at the
Institute for Advanced Study who sort of
spent the early mid 40s early 50s sort
of hopscotching around all the places
where they had
you know nascent computer hardware and
teaching people things and you invented
the stored-program architecture and
things like that so I think you know
this is the kind of thing that if you
have a place which can be good in both
hardware and software and all the other
things that are required to build a
large machine be really exciting so our
goal is to make you know New Haven one
of the places which is known as the
birthplace of this of this new
discipline that would make Yale special
is people and their expertise mm-hmm so
they have people who are here who Rob
did not come here because of quantum
computing but the expertise has had has
a be special niche in the field of
quantum information which was really
precious and then gathered people around
and expertise and ability ok well maybe
this is a good time to ask the President
to come and say a few words or would you
like to say something no I think this
yeah well I just want to say one or two
words about our president so Peter
Saliva's is a well-known psychologist
with expertise in emotional intelligence
and a field which could be relevant to
his current job as well and and not only
that but he's you know been provost and
dean here and it's important in this
context because he is actually the
person that we first pitched this
institute to and I remember him saying I
can't tell you how exciting I find this
idea and even though it's you know we
had a financial crisis it wasn't trivial
to get everything off the ground you
know he's been a strong believer in this
as being an area that where Yale could
be excellent and help Society etc and so
it's very very with great pleasure that
I welcome him to the opening of this
thing that we discussed so many years
ago as the right way to go and now we we
have gone that way
so so
Thank You Doug I appreciate that and
it's good to see so many people up here
in the infirmary of the Yale health plan
so this is just fun for me I get I get
to help not just welcome you all but but
celebrate the launching of the Institute
and actually in a few moments take an
act that will open the Institute
formally so I'm really thank you for
giving me this opportunity it's not very
often that psychologists get to wander
over to physics
although physicists occasionally wander
over to psychology and you know not to
put a damper on the festivities I'm not
going to comment on the quality of that
work that tends to be done it's
psychology by physicists but but in any
case it really is an exciting moment for
me and I'm delighted to share share this
with all of you you know I guess this is
the second information age right and we
are so proud that Yale you know is
playing such an important role in
ushering it in I think for me what's
exciting here is not just the science
which you know people explain to me all
the time and I try to understand
flipping cards at the same time or cats
that are both alive and dead at the same
time all this kind of thing in fact my
assistant joy McGrath chief of staff in
the president's office was working with
the Peabody Museum to give me a a
taxidermied cat to bring with me as a as
kind of a visual aid which I think on
reflection we decided just wasn't really
that good an idea but but for me many of
you have heard me talk about you know a
more unified Yale how do we bring people
together across fields how do we take
advantage of the fact that we actually
are pretty broad in scope here at Yale
but actually everything is kind of
modest in size so it allows you to
groups together across fields more
easily than it might be might be the
case in other places and I think there
is no doubt that the quantum Institute
is it is an example of this
we've got scholars from physics of
course Applied Physics electrical
engineering computer science and people
visiting from all over the world it's
it's really a great thing to see I think
what's also great is the instant kind of
represents a return to to the origins of
people's initial education in this field
what I mean by that is it's kind of the
it's kind of a homegrown success Rob as
you know you know made waves here as an
Applied Physics postdoc in the mid 90s
under the Keen and watchful eye of Dan
prober who I think identified him as
someone who was going to do something
different in his career and now should
feel quite vindicated actually that
seven areas you have as a psychologist
who studies emotion I can see his facial
expression is one of vindication so he
first described by Darwin in his book
the expression of emotion in man and
animals but but it but obviously it's
it's a team effort and you know starts
maybe with the nanostructure physics
team of provigil cough dog but also the
condensed matter group Shankar Nick Reid
and then the their ability to attract
people like Michelle and and Steve's
theoretical contributions Lee no
husband's contributions the young
jeggings you know this is a real team
effort and I love it it's really what I
think Yale can do better than many other
universities bring people together and
turn them loose and I think
that's that's what's happening here so I
get the distinct pleasure of saying to
all of you that I declare on behalf of
Yale University that the quantum
Institute is now open for business
as if they weren't doing business
already but but you know you know in
declaring it isn't enough right
declaring it isn't enough because of
course like all things quantum including
the quantum Institute itself one really
can't be certain that is in fact open
until its state is observed and so so I
understand that what I need to do as
yells president is not just make
declarations usually that's good enough
yeah actually as a social scientist
usually hand-waving is good enough but
but you said it not me
but but in fact I think I'm gonna be the
first Yale president to actually perform
yep a quantum yeah so we the right the
Institute has for a little while been a
bit in a superposition and so we thought
it was appropriate that we would have
you make a measurement so Wolfgang would
you bring the president his button
please over here make sure you press it
the right way okay so let me set it up a
little bit more what we're going to do
here is we're going to link over to labs
across the street in Becton where the
students have prepared one of our qubits
which is microscopic so it's sort of a
Schrodinger cat in a superposition of 0
or 1 or alive and dead and we should
link in to them now and when you push
the button I guess we'll be ready to go
so are we linking to them ok ok yeah so
this looks like something like we're in
for to me light and truth you know if
you okay ready yeah ok there we go
my god
okay you see that the measurement is
there's some noise the measurement is
proceeding Oh Peter
there's something you're trying to tell
me oh okay it looks like so uniform
island right okay so since it was in a
superposition that it's not clear what
should happen the first time so let's
reset okay and we can try it again
everyone okay got to reset the actual
experiment hold on they're working on it
here we go all set
fingers crossed okay
here we go still uncertain still
uncertain okay so pay no attention to
the cat so okay we'll start the
festivities here in a minute let me just
wrap up by saying a few thank you so of
course thank you Peter
and the University and the corporation
for their support this is really an
exciting time for us and I'm sure the
Institute is going to do great things
I would like to thank Wolfgang and
whoever it was in that video I'm not
sure I really recognized the lab or any
other what they were doing over there
but I think many people probably helped
out with that and many people of course
had to contribute to make this day
possible so first and foremost my
longtime teammates friends and comrades
in arms Michele Deborah Steve Griffin
Luigi frenzy oh thank you for the
camaraderie and the teamwork and the
friendship that's made this such a great
thing to do and and and made the team so
successful and I think will do even
greater things there are many other
colleagues to thank but I definitely
want to mention Dan for giving me the
opportunity so many years ago and Lenny
Glassman Lang Jiang Mahseer mera he me
and all the members of Y Qi and the and
the Yale community it's really great I
also did want to single out Doug stone
the deputy director for his support so
he's been chairman of the Applied
Physics Department many times including
when I was hired for the faculty and a
really staunch advocate of this area and
sometimes a combatant on our behalf and
you know this would not have happened
without him pushing for this area so
thanks thank you right for coming for a
wonderful talk yesterday and
participating in the panel and thank you
Joe
for moderating thanks to Carrie
Nordstrom and Nick Kornacki of Yale
facilities for and especially Marty
Cloutier of Shawmut for breaking
buts to get this place almost finished
in time to the staff of Applied Physics
Giselle Terry
Maria Newt for helping out so much but
lastly and most importantly I would like
you to join me in thanking MS Stephane
Hessel let me come around
Stephanie why don't you come on up here
please so those of you who haven't yet
met Stephanie but I doubt there are very
many we've been very lucky to have her
from the inauguration of the of the
Institute as the manager the sort of
heart and soul and the public face of
the Institute and thank you for putting
this all together thanks on behalf of
all that so please stay and explore the
space and we're gonna have some
cocktails and some refreshments there
are two quantum cocktails on offer a red
one and a blue one one is called the
strong measurement one is called the
incoherent state
one is alcoholic one is not you decide
okay thank you everyone